welcome to this video blocks fret never
played him is this new
that's a fairly fresh account okay I
know that one yeah let's see what we get
we should G for know maybe just the
Kings Indian why a more exotic move
order or the old Indian with Bishop e7
yep also a line always go for this this
set up a very natural way to play okay
re routing the night okay it's going 497
f5 and so on and I'm trying to open up
the Queen side in the meantime and five
mmhmm yeah
I normally I want to push a forum
against that so 93 f5f 464 94 okay
that's that's okay at 5 F for mmhmm yeah
F 90 X night at 5 I can take if I if I
think I should be okay then even if I
give up the dark squared Bishop my
central play is just very strong the
knight on e4 especially okay so going to
just take a 5 or I can take I can take
three fives theoretically hmm just play
it keep it simple I can't play d6 in
this position I just wonder if it is
right
d 6 where is he going Bishop F 1 look F
1
look F 1 it's kind of that's kind of
shaky
I can only six he really has no
development so what is happening here
I don't understand any of that I can
take C five I can take F 6
there's even rook f6 rook F see Luke f6
Queen g5 my can we treat the rook okay
mm-hmm can also just take c5 first no
nothing wrong with that if I go Knight
f6 rook f6 Queenie 5s naruki six would
be 6
hmm that's a strange move but maybe
possible and let's take that I don't
know it's probably all good
check I could have taken p7 was checking
I I just saw that but this is this is
just a completely winning position the
pawn on d6 and the monster Queen on e4
blocking the f6 Bishop don't you go here
so Queen b7 is this this is winning
right don't tell me it's not no okay
it's not it's not really necessary I can
also play Queen g4 maybe no Bishop g4
let's trade Queen Sam oh yes to go back
which is not very not very exciting now
okay you went back d7 was six
I see actually going now repent to have
eight
okay then yet might have Ruby seven so I
shouldn't do that okay I'll make sure
that I'm not getting into trouble with
makinia and then a 4 B 5 and so on ad 7
wasn't probably the the cleanest way to
do that Jack mmm I don't need to really
I can play that
or is he playing rook f3m
no I have played this very very badly
giving him some kind of chances
completely unnecessary
okay three
okay three maybe I don't know who kept
three I wanted to go see seven for the
promotion
okay is kind of preparing that but what
is exactly what gave three or what time
was I'm going to going to promote now
against two queens really jack start
with this chicken so I can I can return
one Queen here jack
and the place is seven for the next
Queen check black resigns oh hey Kenneth
I kind of let him back into this it's a
really really badly played
we shouldn't should ever allow that
probably just g3 or something keeping
his Bishop completely out of my position
it would have been would have been okay
yeah the the problem was that he went
for this as usual with with those kind
of one second move yeah where you after
after that he's just lost after Knight
f5 but I I'm getting tired of saying
that I don't understand why they play
half the second moves and then I lost
you know okay then here it is really
really terrible just a question of what
is the best so what is the calm saying
Queen Sofia okay then I played it played
it right I wasn't sure if maybe
something just something into immediate
is working yeah like something like this
but rookie six is kind of hanging on
yeah this kind of thing it's kind of
hanging on this is it is good for white
but it's not okay not as good as this
this is simply check keeping everything
everything together and this pawn and
Ahmad is just just terribly strong what
I should do is I should somehow play g3
maybe just prevent anything coming to f4
and then try to March the pawns up route
d3 this kind of thing this is very safe
and here it gets it gets a bit bit
Shiki check tickets it gets a bit shaky
even if the compass is on +3 all the
time or plus three plus two we went here
and now I went here so yeah it's it's
always winning according to the Machine
but now at computer gives c7 I hope that
wins as well yes yeah he has no she has
no counter play CB 7s also good now but
ok this is this is good enough
Wow so I'm glad that I did not screw
this up I mean result wise and also
playing wise because it was just so
overwhelming you don't want to let black
back into the game
the the matter is that well here here he
really has to think about this he can go
where 5 but after this he has to be very
very yeah circumspect and not take on e4
and play Knight f5 so what what probably
should he do maybe this this is
interesting and 95 for this is a
complicated position I have tonight is 6
possibly but at the moment this is
guarded by night on g7 and Bishop on c8
now it's just as complicated hard to
tell unclear position though the way he
played him he's simply clobbered in the
center I'm so much better developed and
it gets opened up and with d6 he will
lose material okay well thanks for
watching